Beef was listed as a no one by protocol. Would that include grass-fed organic beef,
and is elk, medicine, and buffalo okay to eat? Typically, when beef comes up as a no,
it's no to grass-fed and organic as well, and it's a soft no to elk, medicine, and buffalo as well.
Now again, this can change usually when I test a person and it does come up as meat as a driver,
I do want to recheck that person within 30 days because just in my experience, it changes,
but it doesn't always so. Some of you may be listening to me and you are off of meat and you've
been off of meat for a year or two years or three years and you're doing real well. But
most people that would meet come up a driver, I want to recheck again because most people,
it changes quickly once we cut that out of your diet, clean up the gut, and then a person can go
back on meat so we'll want to recheck that in 30 days.